liberalism is the most intolerant toxic
manipulative extremist thing that's out
there but they're going to make
everything else look like what I just
said and imagine how how dangerous that
is one of the tricks of shaytan is to
convince the world that he doesn't exist
bro
in many ways could be I'll get to be the
reason why they banned you to be honest
with you well I I'm I'm against this
whole idea of liberalism and tolerance
as a whole because one is hypocritical
because these people are not liberal
intolerant the people who are talking
about liberalism intolerance they want
us all to look different but think the
same if you think differently then
you're instantly a bad guy right you
have they love the idea of someone
looking different so they can pretend
they're diverse and tolerant but they
want you to say the same things and
believe the same things as soon as you
step outside of their pre-approved
script instantly they're no longer
tolerant and they no longer they're no
longer interested in diversity of
thought so the first thing that's very
hypocritical and secondly I've learned
in life that the easiest way to get
people to accept bad things is to do it
with a trojan horse you find some way to
disguise it even the Senate does this
even governments do this they'll say you
know the green bill this is to save the
environment and then somewhere on page
84 will be this little code about giving
them all a pay rise you and you don't
want to look at the bad guy who says no
to saving the environment but and they
just sneak it in right so it's very
difficult if you vote against saving the
environment you're terrible and the
media talks about how you didn't want to
save the environment that and you have
to sit there and try and explain on page
84 the MPS are trying to get an extra 45
money and and you're and you're already
in auto back foot and this is how they
do it they do everything with Trojan
horses and it doesn't matter what you
want to name even agendas that are pure
of heart
simple things they end up being
weaponized and Trojan like you just said
second wave feminism and liberalism all
this crazy stuff but the number one the
number one most dangerous one is this
idea of tolerance to sit and talk about
being tolerant sounds like such a good
thing that it's very difficult for
someone to sit and say no I am an
intolerant person now you look bad but
when they say tolerance and push
tolerance to the point where absolute
degeneracy must be accepted then then
you're you're a better person to not be
tolerant you can't be tolerant of
degeneracy you can't be tolerant of your
own children seeing things they
shouldn't see you couldn't be tolerant
of of the destruction of society if
they're going to sit here and say that
no tolerance is the best thing ever and
then Trojan Horsea and and destroy the
way humans interact then I don't think
tolerance is a good thing well I mean
that's the thing they've hijacked the
phrase and they've used it in their own
context there's one particular political
thinker his name is Mumbai he said
something very interesting he said that
the West has not acted morally
consistent they've only acted
strategically consistent yeah and so
it's tolerance when it's within your own
Borders or within a certain subset of
people but then it becomes whatever it
wants it becomes a you know a colonizing
Mission or a civilizing mission when it
comes to you know the Iraq War for
example completely if you look at all of
Western foreign policy I mean they'll
talk about we need democracy we care
about Freedom they can't come up with
all this garbage but the truth is
they'll support any side they want to
support regardless of whether Democratic
regardless of what what team they're on
they don't like you you absolutely
Nutley nailed it it's just about
strategy at the time and they have no
true morals or true moral fiber they'll
just sit there and go what's the
strategical best decision and they'll
get it done and yeah that's Western
foreign policy and I think it's the same
across basically the entire Western
world but this idea when I hear people
talking about tolerance it's just when I
hear it I know what they're trying to do
they're trying to say this is evil this
is bad yeah yeah yeah but you're
intolerant because you don't like evil
and you have there has to be a point
where you stand up as a man and Society
stands up and says yes I'm intolerant of
certain things if someone broke into my
house and tried to just start making
dinner
I'd be like whoa whoa who are you like
be tolerant no I will not be who the
[ __ ] is this guy you know like it
depends on what food is cooking well I
mean there has to there has to be a Line
in the Sand yeah and and the reason they
keep talking about tolerance diversity
inclusion tolerance tolerance tolerance
it's not because they care about
different people of different uh races
or different uh beliefs certainly not
beliefs because you're not allowed a
different belief that's the number one
thing but um it's because they want you
to just sit down and swallow the pill
and allow yourself to be brainwashed and
not stand up for anything that's all
they want this isn't ironic the use
tolerance as a way to try and manipulate
you completely that's what exactly what
they're trying to do in fact and you
know it's funny I'm trying to think of
an idea which is purported and
accelerated by the mainstream media
machine that isn't an attempt on
manipulation like every single thing
that they they jump behind and they try
so hard to get you to believe in is a
manipulation attempt I'm trying to think
of one that isn't yeah why else would
they waste their screen time yeah like
you know they're they're sitting there
these people are smart enough to
understand that the internet's coming
and people are spending more time on
Independent Medias and people are
learning more information from each
other and they're slowly I mean we can I
don't want to go into the subject we can
talk about the last few years they still
have a grip on the world because they
proved it right but
with the with the with the common cold
but still they're sitting there going
okay we have this mass media machine the
average person only watches six minutes
of our propaganda a day they can't waste
those six minutes my friend like they
need to go what's our agendas let's get
to the point what do we need people to
believe about XYZ they can't be sitting
there telling us the truth that's a
total waste of time absolutely do
whatever you want as long as you're not
hurt you know harming other people is so
backwards because you can harm yourself
they don't care and this is the point I
want to make before I before I continue
with my original point they don't care
if you hurt yourself
they don't care if you harm yourself in
America even if you do you know Public
Health Care is not a thing it's
privatized you need to either have a job
that'll pay for it or pay for it
yourself or have some kind of insurance
that costs a lot of money that you
probably don't have the average American
doesn't have they don't care if you hurt
yourself they don't care if you drink
yourself to death they don't care if you
smoke yourself until you lose all your
brain cells they don't care about you
they don't care if you become 500 pounds
obese and die at the age of 36 of a
heart attack while trying to walk up the
stairs that's called that's called body
positivity no
no that's called that's called being
obese and dying at the age of 36.
um but regardless and I'm not even
trying to be rude I genuinely care about
people I want people to live long
fruitful lives the government doesn't
and there's this kind of unspoken train
of thought that people have which is
like if it's if it's illegal it's bad if
it's legal it's okay that's only the
case in Islam if it's Haram it's because
it's bad if it's Halal it's because it's
okay if it's MOBA then it's a bit of a
gray area
yeah like we have these rulings for a
reason the government has it for a
different reason
the our societies have for a different
reason so if you live in a society where
the government and the ideology says
Don't Hurt other people but hurt
yourself they've already failed their
own ideology because they're allowing
you to hurt yourself and making it seem
like what you're doing is not harmful to
begin with they fail at their Crux they
fail at the conception of their own
belief
s
and I just want to kind of slide this in
because it's a little different I don't
know if y'all like catch or caught on to
it but Andrew Chase really like
mentally just like on point with things
like he's very clear-minded and um I
think at one point he said he was uh
doing Carnival diet I don't know if he's
still doing Carnival but like how sharp
he was in his just like mental thought
process and his uh responses and the way
that he could formulate the ideas and
just bring it all together like it only
reminds me of when I was either doing
carnivore keto animal base which is
primarily meat and then fruit honey
stuff like that or in a fasted state
so like this man is doing something like
that and I just I just want to throw it
out there because I don't know if many
people are going to catch on to that but
it's like look at the difference bro
when someone just like mentally sharp
like this
yeah I generally believe he is a smart
guy
um it's what you know it's what my
teacher was saying to us as well that
he's really just dumbing things down for
people but he actually understands a lot
of you know these different concepts and
stuff from the love
what was your initial reaction to the
video
my initial reaction to the video was
I've already had these feelings bro for
a long time but what's weird is when you
have these views where you're kind of
like a lone dissenter they're gonna
paint you as like a conspiracy theorist
or they're going to paint you as you're
backwards you're you're brainwashed your
program your condition subhanallah take
look at how they flip the script bro
you're intolerant like I can literally
already see the headlines from this
video
misogynist uh
misogynist backwards extremist Andrew
Tate now Muslim
foreign
but the thing is the facts are there's
for those you know the facts are there
for those who want them I think most
people don't want the facts because if
the truth is that you know your your way
of life is wrong or you're being taught
a lot of it is wrong uh and so on and so
forth I think a lot of people would
rather continue living that comfortable
life Allah says in the Quran and I'm not
making The Matrix analogy that's
overused I'm gonna reference the Quran
that's the book we should reference
Allah says in the Quran that this life
is nothing but temporary delusion and
they're like these people Allah also
says
these people they love the immediate
what's the immediate the the temporary
delusion they love it they'd rather live
in this temporary delusion and and get
the cars and the women and the men and
all this stuff and and then die you know
at that ripe age of 36 because of uh
their obese heart attack you know like
they don't care
um but yeah I mean at the end of the day
for those who want the truth it's going
to be there we know we know very well
that America Canada
Great Britain back in the day has they
have committed atrocious crimes overseas
in other countries they've they've
committed atrocities who's the first
person to use a nuclear bomb or an
atomic bomb
U.S the US
even look within our own homes look what
they did to the First Nations indigenous
people bro yeah 100 they came in they
they took every single piece of identity
they had like the manateau stone and I
wrote a paper on that recently
and they tried to use it to get them to
come to Christianity to assimilate with
their values and traditions they took
pictures of them in their traditional
outfit and the kid is like slunched over
like this in his traditional cultural
wear and then they have imposing like as
a as a Westerner and he's standing there
like this chest puffed out hands on his
hips like all happy
like they just commented they basically
destroy everything that isn't what's
theirs any other culture any other
belief any other way of life they're
gonna smack smack smack it they're gonna
destroy it essentially and then they're
gonna go back and be like oh why are you
attacking me in my way of life in my be
taller and be tolerant are you stupid
I think liberalism is the most
intolerant toxic manipulative extremist
thing that's out there but they're going
to make everything else look like what I
just said yeah and imagine how how
dangerous that is one of the tricks of
shaytan is to convince the world that he
doesn't exist bro
yeah that's very true that's very true
and I mean if you think about look let's
look at Islamic societies they act like
Islam is not tolerant we actually allow
Jews and Christians that have their own
courts and how and basically do things
according to their book according to
their belief
we don't have that we don't have Islamic
Sharia courts the government doesn't
allow that how are they tolerant of our
belief in our religion if they only let
us practice it within our own
individualistic capacity
you know when the Muslims took over and
they didn't even destroy the idols
people they allowed them to practice
idolatry but then they eventually just
came and practiced this time because
they thought they basically saw the
diamonds of Islam you know metaphorical
diamonds of Islam the gems they're like
I need this what is the statue going to
do for me they accepted Islam and that's
very you know reduced version of the
whole story I'm sure but as I said to
you what happened we don't have that I
talked about this on the episode with
Gabriel you remember that in the summer
in the studio where uh you look at
Canadian law and they will it's legal to
cheat on your girl
but it's like a girlfriend it's
literally illegal to cheat it's legal to
cheat on your wife your girl whatever
but it's illegal to have a second wife
and I know people are going to come in
and be like Oh but you can get in the
car without listen that's not the point
bro that's you guys are missing the
point of course you can do whatever you
want bro you can I'm not saying you can
do this right but how many people drive
above the speed limit and don't get a
speeding ticket
most people right so I'm not I'm not
saying to do it but what I'm saying is
look at the law though
the laws that are there for the
interests of the people supposedly right
it's illegal to cheat on your wife but
it's illegal to have a second wife
so how does that make any sense bro yeah
it doesn't make any sense and like at
the end of the day if they really you
know cared about society and people they
would look at something so basic like
what you just mentioned the fact that
people can cheat on their the people
that they're with and you know break
their heart and they would say listen
let's at least make it official so you
know who's with who let's get like the
wife chicken Center or something which
is this isn't exactly Islamic but if
they actually cared about something like
this they would work to fix this
contradiction they'd be like let's make
sure the the their first spouse you know
um agrees with it they consent uh let's
make sure the person I'm marrying
obviously consents and all this stuff
they don't care they don't care they're
so steadfast on monogamy and pushing
this idea of monogamy probably because
it's just it's just against what other
cultures are doing and they're gonna sit
with it till they die
cheating as well grounds for divorce and
divorce settlement lawyers make bank and
divorce settlement lawyers that make
Bank have to pay Bank to the taxes to
the country so it's a system bro the
whole system's corrupt we're going to
leave it at that we don't want to get
too deep into it but yeah you guys know
the own research so I want to give one
more example because that's something
that it only really clicked for me
recently because I found I found it
within myself as well
you know imagine the headline plus sized
women are not attracted to overweight
men
they call the women plus sized and the
men overweight why not plus size women
plus size men or overweight women
overweight men if I go to a man online
and I say you're fat
nobody is going to care and if I go to a
woman online say she's fat every single
person and their mom and their dad and
their uncle and their dog will be at my
leg biting and yelling at me and barking
at me and I'm not saying you should go
around calling people fat all I'm saying
is people do not care when a lot of
different things happen to men
but they will go an extra 11 miles when
something happens to a woman which I
think is is good that they're protective
of women I think that's good but has
gotten to an extreme now and it's a
double standard and just go go make two
tweets
two tweets one I hate fat men another I
hate fat women and and see what happens
Social Security on Twitter now by the
way you can do that on Twitter because
of Elon Musk